You all have been asking for baby content,
and I met up with one of my sweet followers, Brenna,
the other day, and she gave me so many hand me downs for Baby Jane.
So I wanted to look at some of them
and show you guys some of the adorable baby clothes today.
A little sweater.
Another little sweater.
How adorable. Look at the detail.
Hmm.
Oh, and a blue sweater.
And, of course,
a baby bonnet. Oh,
this is too precious. No,
this is not for you, buddy.
This adorable little dress.
I can't. It's so cute.
I love this, even though it's sad base.
So cute. Oh,
my goodness.
Wow.
She gave me this gorgeous ring sling.
I mean, look at that.
Does that not look like me?
More bones!
Thank you, Brenna.
I'm so excited. Oh,
my goodness. We're having a baby!